Nên thế là cũng đấu tranh rồi, cũng thấy có lợi.
Cái data của em là cái gì?
Cái data em bị outdated.
Cái data của em là cũng không ra dữ liệu.
Nghĩa là kiểu để...
Nghĩa là nếu dùng AI thì nó chỉ học được khoảng 80% thôi.
Thì nó sẽ không học được 20% cái kiểu đặc biệt hơn, kiểu mẫu dài hơn hoặc là...
Nó sẽ phải yêu cầu phải đánh theo keyword, nó phải dài hơn.
Ví dụ như là bình thường các từ như SELECT sẽ đánh luôn chẳng hạn
Nhưng mà một số cụm là nó sẽ không đánh
Thì nó sẽ phải gồm nhiều một cụm nó dài hơn hơn nữa
Cái cụm mà khai thác là đưa lên
Thì bây giờ là AI nó có khả năng suy luận ra về cái đấy rồi
Hay là bây giờ mục tiêu là ngược lại
Là đằng nào AI đã làm được rồi bây giờ mình phải tạo ra một cái mô đun nhỏ
Để cho là AI không phải đưa toàn bộ tất cả các Log qua AI nữa
không nói rất tốn token đấy cả, nó rất là nặng
Token bây giờ không cần nghĩ đến làm gì
Đi đi anh, bởi vì bây giờ là gửi hơn 10 triệu request
và 10 triệu request đấy đều phải đưa
đầu tiên là sẽ đưa qua đánh checklist, đánh check keyword
rồi mới bắt đầu đưa tiếp là lúc đấy vẫn còn hơn 100 nghìn
thì nếu mà tiếp tục AI thì nó sẽ tốn rất nhiều tiền
thì bây giờ phải tạo một cái mô đun nhỏ để nó giảm hiểu cái đồng đấy trước khi đi tiếp
kiểu đưa qua một con AI đần hơn nhưng mà nhỏ hơn và chuyên biệt hơn
sau đó mới đưa con Cloud, bởi vì hầu hết giờ là chỉ có Cloud thôi
nếu mà anh dùng con 200$ cho anh, con đấy nó có con Fable
con đấy là nó được loại bỏ bớt những cái tiêu chuẩn về an toàn thông tin
Nên là nó mới kiểu tình thường là đưa payload vào là nó sẽ thưởng thực thi luôn
Còn Fable nó có mấy cái tiêu chuẩn nó khá thông minh nên là nó khả năng suy luận nó tốt
Nhưng mà con đấy ai mà đi thi Bounty là auto phải luôn
Mình mua gói 100$ thôi vì anh chỉ cần 50$ là đủ
20$ thì hơi nhiều mà anh mới nghe nói là 20$ đấy là 20$ theo quần
Vâng đúng rồi anh
À 20$ theo 5 tiếng
bỏ bỏ luôn nếu mà anh mua không nghĩa là anh sẽ không có giới hạn tuần ai không có giới hạn theo
giờ nữa anh chỉ có dạng phần thôi thế là mấy em từ 5 đến 5 5 5 tiếng người được thành hành
với 5 tiếng đấy không dùng hết đâu không không dùng hết đây anh nếu mà anh thì bao Nếu mà anh
làm bao bác bao ti là sẽ hết bác bao ti là anh anh em là dùng là hết chắc là hết lúc đầu em tưởng
Thấy bỏ ra gần 10 triệu là anh định xài ké
Anh nghe là 200 một người dùng vẫn hết
Bởi vì là Bắc Bạc Ti
Bắc Bạc Ti là nó kiểu
Nó xà vào, nó ôm hết cả cái đồng đấy
Thì đương nhiên là
Anh ấy vẫn sẽ đưa logic vào nhưng mà không tối ưu được
Mấy em cũng không ít
Nó đang quay vào đó
Có nghĩa là
Cục thi nghìn đô
Bỏ 200 là cũng lời
275 triệu
Là 7 triệu 8
20 triệu nào
Thì là gần 10 triệu đi anh
10% ván
Anh quên
Tại vì sáng nay ngóng vừa, nhắn cho anh kìa, build vừa rồi
Vậy, thì đấy, thì bây giờ...
Từ...
Đúng rồi, nó thêm 10%
Thì đấy, bây giờ bài toán là tiết kiệm hiệu năng rồi
Vì gần như là cứ ném cloud với công ty một người
Nó gần như vượt trộn
Nên là bây giờ là suy ngược lại
Sử lý hai cái
Một là tạo ra một con module rất là bé
Và nó xử lý được những cái cơ bản
2 là mình sẽ phải xử lý những cái cực kỳ khó
Nghĩa là mô hình của em phải học được
Cái cú pháp
Cái câu rất là khó
Có thật sự là tầm mô hình không?
Có chứ anh
Vì
Nhan là chỉ là xin dữ liệu
Nghĩa là bây giờ là bộ dữ liệu
Nó sẽ chỉ có 2 câu tầm công thôi
Thì nghĩa là chỉ có 2 câu tầm công thôi
Thì 2 câu tầm công đấy
Không có quá nhiều thông tin để mình học
Rồi mình sẽ sao hết tất cả lên
để cho nó cố gắng học. Ví dụ như là bây giờ em có 50 câu, trong đó chỉ có 2 câu tấn công rất là đặc biệt, rất là kiểu chuyên biệt
thì đưa vào mô hình thì nó chỉ học 48 câu còn lại, 2 câu kia nó cho rằng là thứ yếu nên nó sẽ bỏ qua.
Từ bây giờ là phải làm dầu bằng cách chỉ 2 câu đấy thôi, nhưng mà sinh ra được 50 câu rồi đưa vào thì nó sẽ chỉ tập trung vào...
Nhưng mà hiện tại em đưa vào một tường lửa mã nguồn mở, Mode Security
Mode Security là NGX đúng không?
Dạ, NGX
Và từ giờ nó vẫn là OSI
Không, cái đấy thì em không dựng nổi, cái đấy nó dựng hơi khó
Vâng thì không, kể cả dựng Docker thì em cũng chỉ dựng được Mode Security thôi
Đang đấy nó cũng thuộc dạng trung bình, nó cũng vừa thủy khó
Em mới dựng về đấy thôi
Cora-Za, có thể dùng rule của Mod Security nhưng mà nó không có line
Em và các em có thử Cora-Za với Mod là nó phải dùng rule set chung
CRS
Còn về cơ bản là hai thằng như nhau mà thằng này được tùy chỉnh nhiều hơn
Nếu mà chuyển khai ban đầu thì dễ hơn nhưng mà nhiều cái phải setting nha
Thằng kia gọi lên phát rồi em ru cái là xong
Em mới có MDX không phải cấu hình MDX nữa
Em chưa biết anh chắc gì kì của thằng đi vào thằng Docker
Đấy thì đối với em thôi thì em chỉ cần gõ mấy code
Và thằng này thì phải custom bằng tay hơi nhiều. Như là trước thì em phải dùng lạc này, nhưng mà sau phát hiện là docker liên kết với chắc gì thì thế là thôi.
Docker là có mcp đúng không?
Đúng rồi anh. Nghĩa là cứ cái gì liên quan mcp của thằng. Cứ cái gì mcp là mắc nó đồng hoạt được.
Anh không biết cái đấy nhưng mà anh chưa dùng. Anh chưa dùng cái đấy thì anh ít dùng docker desktop lắm. Không dùng docker desktop bao giờ. Dùng cái server là chính.
Mỗi cái là nó hơi bị quá tay nên đôi lúc em không ý thức là mình đang làm cái gì.
Nếu mà mình không theo cửa bài ai, nó là một tràn text của người đọc
Đọc xong nhưng mà vẫn chưa hiểu, có 8 câu hỏi, 10 câu hỏi để hỏi lại
Mà mình hỏi những câu hỏi xong nó lại quên cái đoạn đấy đi
Thế ờ, người ai không cần chỉ đọc sâu, nhanh, có đúng 3 tháng mà của em nó bị lỗi thời
Như của anh cũng bị lỗi thời, ngày xưa ở cái thời mà 2025
Rồi cái đề tài của anh trước thì còn
Nó sẽ là tấn công, nó sẽ bị tấn công rất là nhiều
Nhưng mà bây giờ thì hầu hết là các mô hình có cả Trails rồi
Không được, chỉ là nếu người dùng là dùng Cloud thì đề tài sẽ không có tác dụng
Nhưng mà nếu người dùng là dùng các cái
Nó là doanh nghiệp, doanh nghiệp mà tự xây LM thì nó là ok
Không, chỉ cần liên quan, chỉ cần không dùng Cloud thì đề tài nào cũng có thể được
Thằng đấy nó kiểu
Cái bản Cloud của nó là mô hình cộng với cái hát nét của nó
Thằng đấy hát nét kinh
Do cái ông Andrew NG tổ cái đấy
Thì đấy, giờ chỉ có đúng rồi
Bây giờ tôi yêu chi phí này vì là về trí đồng minh là không thể hơn được mà kiểu hơn nó cũng không tốt hơn được đấy anh
Bây giờ anh dùng nghĩa là cloud cộng với cả skill hnet, anh biết skill hnet không anh?
Nhưng mà bình thường skill là em phải viết script
Ví dụ như em muốn tải một cái video em phải viết chi tiết là script và nó sẽ phải tải, chạy câu lệnh như thế nào, thay thế từ ngữ như thế nào
Bây giờ anh chỉ cần viết ít context cho nó, nó tự động biết cần phải làm gì
Skill là một level tốt hơn của Adnet thôi
Vâng, không nghĩa là có skill và skill Adnet đi anh
Nhưng mà bây giờ thiết tải cũng không làm được rồi
Bởi vì các thằng khác là yêu cầu phải viết chi tiết xem là nó cần phải làm gì
Ừ, thế này cũng có, chỉ là nói chưa được kỹ là cloud rồi
Codec cũng có một cái dùng nó cũng ok, nhưng mà giờ mua thì phải codec thôi
Codec là thiên về người thực thi hơn
Nghĩa là nếu dùng codec để thực thi thì nó sẽ tiết kiệm token hơn, còn về xử lý thông minh thì nên dùng hàng cloud
Với đầu anh dùng codec này em cũng nghĩ là ok, nhưng mà nó có vẻ phá phát quá nhiều như là
Thấy em ví dụ là em phát một tên tên tên tên docker nó sẽ dễ hơn một tiếng
Nó không được mượt mạng và lô lông nhiều, ở kia mình cũng nói rất là nhiều
Ok, đúng thì một thằng hơi tốn tiền, hoặc thì nó sẽ gần như gặp vô hạn
Hồi đấy là anh dùng codec lúc nào cũng cũng thuộc vào rạng 200$ ý
Nên lúc đấy em cũng cảm thấy nó research khá là khỏe, vừa research vừa...
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Còn với slide thì anh thấy hoạt động của đấy
Thì nó hỗ trợ kia hơn
Tạo slide, viết doc
Thôi anh hãy dùng thằng đấy để viết slide
Đấy phải nên
Đáng lẽ phải nên ngược lại nhưng mà thôi kìa
Ngược lại sao?
Nghĩa là nếu như mà anh dùng thằng
Nghĩa là thằng Cloud nó chỉ hành chạy lần đầu thôi
Còn lại những cái tinh chỉnh bé bé thì dùng thằng Codec để tính kiện
Chạy lần đầu thôi anh hãy sửa lại
Đúng rồi, anh phải sửa lại mà lúc đấy thì hãy dùng làm codec
Ờ đây, không, dưới codec thì...
Ok
Sửa lại cũng cũng thôi, cho nó với đoán của mình rồi lấy
Vì lúc đấy em thì cũng lấy slide mẫu của máy khoa thôi mà sửa thêm logo mới này
Rồi nó mới chế ra cái đồng đấy
Nhưng mà có đúng mấy cái là em...
Có đúng 4 mô hình mà em dùng AI thì các thầy dã là...
Nhiều chữ quá
Đúng rồi
Thầy họ bảo anh cũng theo, hỏi nhiều vai để bỏ phần câu hỏi luôn
Khi nào các thầy hỏi thì cứ ưa ơn
Tại vì nói cái đấy nó chỉ là cái phương phủ luật của người thầy
Chỉ là một cái mà từ đấy mình suy nghĩ ra một cái gì đấy
Thì em nghi trong nhóm là đặt vấn đề này, các nghiên cứu trước có gì này
Xong rồi xem triển khai thế nào trong cái đoạn bù hát tầm 10 phút là xong rồi
Nhưng mà nghĩ lại thì có khi cứ làm cái cách cũ hay hơn
Anh Hải, anh Hải công an
Anh ấy thuyết trình hết 40 phút
Xong rồi các thầy không hỏi được gì
Cho 8-6 đi về
Không hỏi đúng 1 câu
Lúc đầu lít ra là hỏi 7 câu
Nhưng mà không kịp, họ trả được đúng 1 câu
Rồi đi về
Anh ấy
Anh ấy mới cân bằng
Nhưng mà anh còn giỏi là được
Bất cứ ai cũng giỏi, trên 8 ai cũng giỏi
Không, khả năng là bạn Ngọc Anh kia sẽ khá
Bởi vì 7.5 là hơi nó kéo kinh
Đấy chắc phải chiếm 70%
Còn mấy cái điểm 8 chấm ở trên trường chỉ chiếm 0.13
Cũng do là các bạn cũng quá tự tin vì cái đề tài là khó quá
Chắc là các thầy dí cho tốc đề xuất thì các thầy nhé bác thầy
Đề xuất đề một giọng dễ bị hỏi quá
Cái đấy là chuyên việt ấy, cũng rộng như vừa rồi một chuyên việt
Và cái mà mọi người chọn là những thứ biết luật
Vâng thì thầy thắng thì ngồi thư ký thì bốn hay kia cũng càng
Thắng ngồi thư ký là chân chết rồi
không thể thắng ngồi thư ký bởi vì thầy kiểu có gì chết là thầy còn kiểu chữa cho các kiểu nói, làm nói tránh
đỡ
vâng, nói đỡ
em là thầy chung ngồi thư ký nha
thế là thầy cũng nói đỡ nên em biết là nếu mà để mấy cái thầy hay hỏi mà làm thư ký là chỉ có thể là nói đỡ
đúng là nói đỡ hơn
nhưng mà như là chủ tịch và thư ký là sẽ không đổi
còn sẽ thay đổi thủy viên
không, chỉ có chủ tịch và sẽ không đổi được
thư ký có đổi
thư ký sẽ đổi
Anh là thầy bảo vẫn ngồi đấy, nhưng thường sẽ đổi
Chỉ có chủ tịch sẽ được giữ, đổi hết
Chủ tịch yêu cầu Phó giáo sư đổi, hoặc là trên đại tá
Như thầy Tuấn Anh, thầy thảm sát nhiều quá, không thể lên Phó giáo sư được
Thầy Tuấn Anh năm... nhưng là thầy có con rồi, còn hồi 2014, thầy về thầy Thắng và phụ huynh đã đem hoa đến rồi, vẫn cho trường.
Càng đưa thầy càng kỹ.
Không, như là kiểu thầy gia đình cho trường, và giờ thầy hiền nó.
Thầy nói như thế là như thế, không ai kiểu...
Thì lúc đầu thầy Thắng thì thầy Thắng đấm em lõm hết đầu không cho em vào về tuần nghiệp, thầy thi tuần nghiệp.
Vâng, đợt thầy mới về là em năm 2, đấy kiểu vẫn hơi hơi...
Em là AT16
Em là AT16, tầm...
Tầm 5 năm là thế
Vâng, đấy là cũng bị lễ hái của thầy Tuấn Anh với cả thầy Thắng, thầy Bảo.
Thầy bảo là thầy khèo kinh hóa. Thầy cũng bình thường thôi nhưng mà nếu mà thầy có vấn đề, đúng rồi, thầy mở ra vấn đề, thầy toán hỏi kỹ hơn, thầy thắng hỏi sâu hơn, thế là chết.
Thầy có một câu hỏi đôi khi không liên quan chứ không phải là câu hỏi của người khác.
Nhưng mà nếu không trả lời kỹ chứng tỏ cái câu hỏi vấn đề là chết.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh Ghiền Mì Gõ Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Về dạng một môn hoặc là đi tiệm
Thì thầy về
Thầy
Vâng
Hơi đen vụn nga với cả là
Cry
Giống anh Hùng Anh với cả anh Mình
Rồi không thoát được
Nghĩa là mấy anh ấy là yêu cầu
Sau khi học xong rồi phải có 5 năm
Cống hiến cho học viện
Nhưng không
Nhưng mà không ai mời về
Không mời về thì không tích thời gian được
Như là kiểu anh ấy mới được tính khoảng 2-3 tháng thôi, đôi lúc đe gọi về giấy, không được tích thời gian, nhưng mà cũng không được kiểu rứt đường, cứ bị ở giữa, cứ chôn.
Đấy là đầu chiến tranh đó, chưa anh?
Dạ?
Đã được mà không anh?
Chưa, không anh ấy về được 3 năm rồi. Đợt đấy là đã bị rồi anh.
Đợt nào?
Nghĩ chắc là thêm mấy mấy năm nữa thôi vì là Nga nào cũng thắng rồi giờ phải câu, câu kiểu để Mến Úc Châu yếu cũng chưa biết được anh.
Nhưng mà làm với Gu bây giờ thì sau năm 2026 thì anh...
AI ạ.
AI nó kiểu nó sẵn sàng động vào mấy cái an toàn thông tin, an toàn thông tin nó cũng...
Anh em làm pen test được thì NLC cũng làm được. Giờ anh em pen test đi tìm bất kỳ người ai để investigate.
Thì hôm nay em cũng có nói thì anh ấy cũng có nói là bây giờ chỉ ném cái mindset là thôi, còn lại là nó sẽ chủ động.
Và cái quan trọng nhất là cái case study là cái quan trọng nhất.
Hãy subscribe cho kênh lalaschool Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn
Để em đọc tiếp
Nghĩa là vứt hết tia 1 à?
Tia 1 chỉ có V5 và AI thôi
Chẳng vứt Alex nhiều
Thế thì mất hết việc
Mất được phải tiến hóa thôi
Tia 1 phải cố lên thôi như thế nào?
Tia 1 cố không được, giờ chỉ có đẩy thẳng lên tia 2 thôi
Thì đúng, nghĩa là tia 1 phải cố ăn súng tỏa
Thử lý được vấn đề đấy thì nó sẽ lên được
Chứ có tầm tia 1 lên tia 2 đâu
Vừa vào đã thành tia 2
Không có vấn đề
Có những ông không trực mà chỉ làm D2 thôi, tất cả các ông như thế này. Chỉ chuyên đi tùy mạng
quen của các chủ tịch xăng chủ động thôi chứ không hỗ trợ
Hỗ trợ chính là gần như bỏ gần hết
Chắc đúng như thế, mong mọi người yên tĩnh
Và cái dây chuyền mà có alert và cái tiêu chuẩn về alert này như thế nào, có AI nào, có follow như thế nào
Trước em nghe đóng cây bằng AI, đã thấy không giòn
Đóng cây này, từ cây đấy mang đi một loại loại veritip này, bổ sung trên evidence này
xong từ Evidence đấy kích xuất
quay ngược về Endpoint nhé
lấy Artifact về
lấy Analyze cái tại Artifact đấy
như là e nghe chẳng hạn kiểu kìa đấy
Vậy nhưng mà nước ngoài ai đã làm chưa mà
hay là
cũng sản phẩm hãng đang làm đấy
không kiểu nội bộ vậy anh
hay là mình vẫn phải
nghĩa là mình phải dừng đến hãng hay là kiểu mình làm nội bộ
không, mình làm nội bộ vẫn được
MISA đang làm đấy rồi
MISA hả
Misa hả? Misa, Misa là công ty Misa, Misa giấu ý
Không em biết rồi
Misa lần này đi bootcamp có tiền tiền lần đấy
Người ta không bắt đầu lên mạng, người ta không đuổi ai thì không được
Năm sau bootcamp này chắc là người ta sẽ put slide lên thôi
Bootcamp hôm nào đấy anh?
Hôm nay ngày cuối rồi
Có gì chắc là anh cho em xem, em cũng không...
Năm nào cũng có slide mà. Năm ngoái là bắt đầu nói về Autonomous Energy.
Có khi làm không nhanh 2 tháng ở khi nói cái của em phải lỗi thời tiết.
Thầy kêu phải tiến hóa thôi.
Công nghệ cổ kỳ luôn. Nhanh thật.
Bây giờ kiểu làm biệt tá không phải chứng minh mình hỗ trợ AI cái gì.
cái này
hình thái mới
mục tài nguyên
chắc là hiện tại thì em chưa post lên nhưng mà
hai ngôi năm thì nó có này
Facebook thì người ta sẽ nói là YouTube Bootcamp Misa
các em thấy rồi
Như thế này là giới thiệu của Securitibootcamp nhé
Từ nay đến cuối năm thì còn sự kiện kiểu đánh tập trận
Đấy gọi là gì nhé?
Đánh diễn và thực chiến
À diễn vâng
Nhưng mà nếu như Securitibootcamp thì không có cái nào nữa
Nhưng mà có thể sẽ có Smart Banking
Smart Banking thì Security là thứ yếu đi cạnh
Nó sẽ tổ chức thi đấu ở đấy
Như là nội bộ ấy
Không, các ngân hàng
Thi giữa các ngân hàng ấy
Anh vào feed anh có gặp bạn Phong hả anh?
Anh ở chỗ khác
Chỗ khác
Đặc biệt hơn
Điêu anh có được trên 4x không anh?
Trên 4x
Đến từ WinShot cũng giống mà về...
Anh...
Năm nay
Em chưa gặp, vâng rồi
Anh làm cùng anh?
Còn đây là Misa
Trường Misa
Misa
Rồi
Ai xem thức AI
No, nó mất defense
Nó không nếp việc đâu
Không, đương nhiên là không nhanh
Và cái đề tài của thêm không nhanh là cũng ngon ngoẻo
Ừ, nên nhanh
Nhưng mà đối với người nghiên cứu thì nhanh chậm nó khốn nha lắm
Giờ thì có rồi
Không, đối với người nghiên cứu thì không nhanh thì sẽ vẫn có cách khác để người ta làm
Tức là người ta không phải là người nghiên cứu chỉ hôm nay thôi
Người ta nghiên cứu là người ta tiếp tục chuyển đổi chủ đề
Người khác thì người ta vẫn không thể
Chuyển đổi chủ đề cũng hơi khó
Không nhưng mà chuyển đổi chủ đề phải theo thầy nữa
Bởi vì là
Khi nào em lên tiến sĩ
À khi nào em lên phó giáo sư em mới được quyền tự chủ
Còn thầy Phạm Duy Trung là thầy đang theo một thầy
Đây là thầy Bùi Thu Lâm ở thiên trường
Thầy à
Thầy mà dạy mình môn
Học máy
Học máy đấy
Thì thấy bị hồ sơ bị bỏ vấn đề
Nên là không lên được
Còn trước là thấy là bên trường quân sự
Vâng
À đấy biết cắt
Vâng đúng rồi
Thấy trước là cũng kiểu sắp lên
Không biết
Cũng sắp lên phó
À cũng lên phó hiệu trưởng
Nhưng mà bị cái liên quan tới mở lớp
Mở lớp dạy thêm thì không được tính là
Đó là kiểu tiền khô
Anh không biết vụ đấy nhưng mà anh chỉ biết là một tục tạm mà không trở nên
Đấy thì bị cái đấy thôi bởi vì mỗi lớp dạy thêm ngoài, dạy thu tiền
Và hồi đấy thì cứ nghĩ là phải dạy để dạy từ tấm lòng của thầy là khô xong
Thế là gọi là dòng tiền không minh bạch, dính
Và thầy thích rất đến cái đấy
Vâng, thầy cũng thích
Nhẹ nhàng, nhẹ nhàng
Thì cái đấy bị uống hồ sơ thế là thầy bị kẹt
Ờ, hiện tại thầy cũng theo thầy đấy
Nhất là bình thường là cứ thứ bảy hàng tuần là sẽ có một buổi giữa các nghiên cứu sinh thì em được ngồi ké
Vì kiểu em ghi tên mấy vào
Tức là em mới tự tin là ít nhất là đề tài em nhắc nhắn trên tám vì thấy mà không ok em không bao giờ ra bảo vệ
Về em bảo vệ muộn thì mãi thấy ok không thì có khi nhanh hơn nhiều
Cái đề tài này của anh lâu lâu anh ngó vào một tí, không có nhiều thời gian được
Cũng may là em nghĩ là giai đoạn của anh ngó kịp
Đúng đấy
Vì là mới thông báo 2 tuần
Anh dự trù công việc lâu từ trước rồi, chỉ là anh không ngó vào kịp
Lên đề cương thì lên đề cương trước 1 tuần thôi
Thế cũng may em vừa mới nhắn tin cho anh Hải lớp trưởng là khả năng sẽ bảo vệ sớm
Bởi vì thầy hiệu phó sắp phải luân chuyển công tác
2 hôm sau đã nhận tin là 12 đảng chí bảo vệ
Bình thường là phải nộp, gửi các thầy, tạm biệt rồi sửa lại một lần nữa, rồi gửi lại lần cuối.
Cái này cô ý anh có thể cắt hết đoạn AI đi, nhưng mà bỏ qua hết thì rất là may mắn.
Đỡ bao nhiêu bước làm nhẹ cũng được.
Chưa sẵn sàng bảo vệ.
Không sao, anh thấy cái quy mô thì anh cũng biết là nó rất là dễ.
Sáng anh có đi dạo một vòng hay hình thế?
Chắc là chết mỗi một người thôi
Em cảm giác là mình không nên chọn đề tài
Nghĩa là em biết là chuyên biệt rồi
Nhưng mà nó quá rộng để hỏi
Rộng là không người cũng biết
Nếu mà đi theo thầy mà không tự tin thì tự tìm một cái
Nếu mà em tự vẽ ra đường thì sẽ không ai bắt vẽ em cả
Em đi theo đường người khác thì...
Đi theo người khác thì phải tâm trí hơn
Mình bị thú động hay tự động?
hello hello đang đang đang ok ok ok
ngoài cái autonomous còn giờ còn có cái gì bên LOC cần phải biết không anh
đấy autonomous đấy là chỉ bên LOC thôi còn bản forensic và internet response đúng không
còn nhiều hay như nào anh
ý là có những mảng khác nữa mà
vâng thì em đang quan tâm đến khách intelligent hơn
khách intelligent mà có AI á
có chứ anh
có ừ không ý là anh đang muốn hỏi em em muốn có AI trong đấy hay là như nào
ừ đúng rồi anh
Mục tiêu của em là khi bảo vệ thì sẽ làm 2 cái
Một là thêm cái keyword để cho thằng tượng lửa nó quét mạnh hơn
Hai là sẽ ném một thằng AI vào giữa thằng tượng lửa với cả thằng AI chính
Một con mô đun nhỏ hơn để giảm thiểu cho ví dụ thằng Cloud ở hạng nó rất là khỏe
Nó sẽ sàng lọc thêm
Thì sẽ là kiểu bảo vệ băng
Thì sau đó thì nó phải dựa trên một bộ TI chứ anh
Cái con mô đun bé của em là nó phải dựa trên TI
Đồng ý, đồng ý. Ok đây, nhưng mà CoTi đâu cần phải AI.
Con TI đấy nó chỉ ghi một vài cái câu lệnh, ví dụ như là một câu tấn công mới nhất chẳng hạn.
Như vừa mới tấn công ngân hàng VIP chẳng hạn, thì khả năng sẽ tấn công ngân hàng MB.
Thì mới thu thập được một hai câu thôi.
Mà muốn đưa vào mô hình AI thì phải nhân dọng nó cực kỳ nhiều lên.
mình không thể ctrl c ctrl v được
bởi vì nó chỉ giảm học đúng một mẫu
cái thật không thể đổi mẫu liên tục
cái này cũng như là ngoài tầm của TI rồi, cái này vẫn là GAN thôi
không nhưng mà ý là đầu tiên là có TI, giờ phải làm đến nào mà GAN nó phải học được, thì hút đấy mới nhân
thế thì thử mấy cái project open source kiểu MISC ấy
để nó chỉ là môi trường của TI thôi
môi trường của TI
tức là nó là một cái pool để em lấy nguồn nước ngoài
MISC
nguồn tên rồi thì cái nó nó chỉ là một cái ôm xuống cho em kéo ra những nguồn cộng đồng về và
đấy sẽ nuôi được cái đấy để em phát triển ra nhân nhân dưới lên nhưng mà anh không không biết cái
gần gan tự thi ai như thế nào thì không anh nhanh anh cứ hiểu chỉ đơn giản anh biết là nó sẽ hết rồi
với ý là cái MSP hay là những cái nguồn TI khác, CTI thì nó chỉ có nguồn thầu hết là các IOC
Đa số là thế, IP, Domain hoặc là Pilot mấy cái đấy đều là IOC
thì IP và Domain anh không biết nó gen ra kiểu gì, còn Pilot thì may là có thể
Nói thật ra IP với cả thường bị đánh chặn
những cái này là cái specific nhất
không thường hai cái đấy là bỏ qua
cái đó là hash
hash với cả
hash với cả gì hash nhỉ
imhash
imhash là một phần
tức là để theo dõi nhiều họ một lúc ấy
thì người ta đem được imhash
một loại hash của những cái có liên quan đến cái hash này
ví dụ là binary này import
những thư kiện nào ấy
imhash nó sẽ chỉ dưới cái phần chung đấy thôi
nhưng mà nếu mà em tải
Nhằm tải mấy cái thư viện, một vài cái thư viện, và người chung thì nó sẽ đánh vào
Nó sẽ tính ra là cái in-house và có thể biết là họ này với họ này có liên quan đến nhau không, có chung một mẹ hay không, kiểu gì đấy
IOC có nhiều kiểu lắm, em phải lựa xem là IOC nào có thể dạy gan được, IOC nào có thể dùng tận dụng, rồi mới tính tiếp được
Đấy là nếu nó hướng dưới ai
Còn ở Core 6 thì nó sẽ phải unpack và tìm tác tích của mỗi cái Artifact ấy
Ví dụ là Manware gì đấy, cái đấy phức tạp hơn nữa
Cái đấy thì em không làm được
Cái đấy thì hơi sâu về phần Assignment
Ừ
Đấy thì Adem lại chưa được làm được thôi
Em chỉ làm cái bề kiểu nông nông
Tập trung vào mấy cái tầng thông web
Em chỉ tập trung vào mấy cái tính công web trước
XSS, SVL là 2 cái
Em hãy đi từ các nguồn CVE
CVE sẽ để lại exploit code để tạo ra GAN
Em cũng làm yêu thương đấy nhưng mà
Bên đấy nó kiểu đặc thù quá
Các CVE không thể liên hệ với nhau được
Nhưng mà các biến thể này nó không có tính liên kết với nhau anh, bởi vì là mỗi một câu là phải có ngữ pháp riêng ý anh, ví dụ như là học kiểu 10 ngữ pháp là em cũng chưa làm được, nó rất dễ bị trồng trèo ý anh.
Nó dễ bị vô nghĩa, nó chỉ đơn giản là ghép với nhau như Lego vậy anh
Kiểu anh có cái tàu Lego anh tháo ra
Thế nên là kể cả là nó có độc nhất thì ít nhất phải có các tính liên kết
Nó kiểu phải có ngũ pháp
Như SQL
Vâng, hiện tại SQL, XSS là 2 cái mà dễ nhất rồi
Còn tấn công như kiểu là đi đốt vào mấy cái kia là khó quá
Mấy cái kia là kiểu gây nhiễu
Thế là nó dùng đủ mọi cái
Thế thắng là làm cái khác
Thế thắng là làm liên quan tới
Phần mềm
Cái của thầy thắng
Cái thắng sẽ
Công kinh hơn
Thắng như là có nghiên cứu cả UAV mà
Thầy Thắng giờ chắc là không làm được gì nữa
Thầy phải gồng ghê quá
Bây giờ đang sát nhập 2 cơ sở vào
Lên lại văn phòng
Sao đến rồi?
Học báo cuối rồi
Học báo đến 5h
Ý là hết tên ảnh
Mặt giỏi của anh
Với người ít duy nhất đây
Cái gì là góng phát là cả 1 lớp
Không muốn nhắc về tình
Hãy subscribe cho kênh La La School Để không bỏ lỡ những video hấp dẫn